[Music]
foreign then for the Press preview a
first look at tomorrow's front pages and
checking out those front pages with me
tonight the guardian's chief political
correspondent Jessica elget MPR
consultant Alex Dean they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight very
good evening to both of you we'll chat
in a moment after we've had a look at
some of those front pages Britain's next
prime minister sunac leads Johnson reads
the I
The Daily Telegraph well they're
focusing on the leading support among
conservative mps4 Mr sunac's second bid
for number 10 the bid the former
Chancellor is yet to publicly announce
well the Ft leads on worries by
investors and some Tory MPS concerned
about the very idea of Johnson's return
to number 10.
the times has a harsh take on that
highlighting a warning from Lord Hague
that it could spark a Tory death spiral
Boris I'm up for it we are going to do
this The Daily Express leads on those
remarks reported by Johnson Ally Sir
James dudridge remarks we've heard here
at Sky as well same as the sun I'm up
for it they say
a photograph of the former prime
minister and his wife holidaying in the
Caribbean covers the front page of the
mirror it's 80 000 signed the papers
petitioned calling for a general
election
while the Daily Mail has word on
reported efforts by senior Tori MPS to
broker a deal to unite Mr Johnson and
Rishi sunak
while according to the guardian Tory
tribes are going to war
and the Daily Star continues its
salad-based satire of British politics
at their headline they've tossed aside
the lettuce now they're serving up the
aubergine
and just to remind you you can scan the
QR code that you can see on screen join
the program and check out the front
pages tomorrow's papers while you watch
us discussing them and I'm joined
tonight by Jessica elgett and Alex Dean
great to see you both this Friday
evening so much to talk about
um Jessica why don't we start with your
paper and your front page uh for
Saturday Tory tribes go to war is a
headline a picture there of Penny Morton
the only candidate so far to formally uh
say that she is up for it a picture of
Rishi sunak as well no word from him but
his supporters say he has reached that
magic 100 and they're at the bottom
Boris Johnson who we are told is up for
it
yeah and I think it's really interesting
if you look at the uh the nominations
for each one you can basically see
exactly how the Tory party uh divides up
um you can see um you can pretty much
map how many
um votes Boris Johnson might have got if
there'd have been a confidence vote in
him a second time round just before he
left which uh he was advised he would
lose and and I think you know Tori MPS
was saying to me yesterday I thought
that he could probably get about 60 70
maybe 80 MPS to endorse him but they
didn't think that he would get to a
hundred and that's what he's got to to
do over the next few over the next few
hours he uh he's really got to make a
call I think by um tomorrow afternoon
about whether he's actually going to
formally declare that he's standing or
not
um in a way that only Penny Morton has
uh so far
um and um he will only do that if it
looks like he's certain to reach the
threshold as Richie sunac already has
tonight yeah so this time next week Alex
we will have a new prime minister who do
you think it's going to be
well I actually think it's likely to be
Boris Johnson I think that
um these numbers the most interesting
thing to come out of them of course it's
no great surprise that Rishi sunak has
made these numbers because of course he
won uh the rounds amongst members of
parliament um last time when Liz truss
went to the final two with him the
biggest story from this uh the declare
number so far is how low penny mordant
is suggesting that the two
um people who've been either at Water
the knife with one another or might make
up depending on who you believe uh Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson are a final two
and unless you're going to see lots of
abstentions and I doubt very much that
that's going to happen I think the votes
are going to pile up enough for Boris
Johnson to make it over the hundred I'll
be honest I didn't think that 48 hours
ago but talking to people in around
Westminster look at what people are
saying and thinking I think if Boris
declares he's going to get over 100 and
I think if once he goes to the party
membership he wins in a landslide yeah
front page of the Daily Telegraph
picture of Richie sunak see that races
to secure majority of Tory MPS is that
your thinking Jessica that we're looking
at a a sunak versus Johnson vote
I think so and I think and I think if if
Rishi sunak and Boris Johnson are put to
the membership then then like Alex says
I think that it's very likely the
membership will will
um will pick Boris Johnson and and you
know they've already rejected but she's
seen that once
um so it's really up to MPS now if they
if they really feel strongly enough to
to just to um to want to stop
um uh Boris Johnson then they need to
just pile all of their all of their
votes behind Scenic and try and try and
arrange a coronation on Monday
um I mean I think that that's obviously
what people in you know who are who are
behind Scenic are hoping will happen
um but I think you know like everybody I
think there's been some surprise at the
number of people who even people who
wrote you know letters of no confidence
or said that they would resign but
because of Boris Johnson's leadership
now a lot you know as now saying that
they're backing him again for leader and
I I and it's interesting to kind of
understand the the psychology uh behind
that I suspect people have been so
spooked by the polls and that have been
given given labor such an enormous lead
and given that you know putting their
their conservatives in Oblivion
territory that they think the only
person they can possibly go back to is
someone who's who's previously delivered
them an election Victory but of course
the polls have changed an awful lot in
terms of what the public think about
Boris Johnson they they they don't see
him particularly in that way anymore but
you can see why some Tory MPS think why
would we not you know try the man who
won it for us last time we're in
remarkable times Alex aren't we I mean
it is quite staggering front page of the
sun uh Boris breaks his silence I'm up
for it I mean Boris Johnson had 148
wasn't it of his colleagues vote against
him in that confidence vote in June
followed by nearly 60 ministerial
resignations one month later and here we
are looking at a possibility of him
being back in number 10.
well if he does it it's the biggest
political comeback of all time isn't it
I mean so quick as well as so
significant but look Jessica's been
right on on everything she said but
there's two very specific things I pick
out first of all Tory members of
parliament don't want to have an
election right now for the very reason
that she uh describes that they think
they would do very badly and there'd be
rather fewer of them and there's a lot
of talk in the country of course about
the next prime minister needing a
mandate and you can't have possibly a
third prime minister without having a
general election well Boris Johnson won
the general election in 2019 and there's
a school of thought that says this may
convince people or not but there's a
school of thought that says uh that
Boris Johnson has that mandate because
he won in 2019 and secondly Jessica is
also right to point out uh that um
plenty of these people Express their
confidence in Boris Johnson either
privately in their votes or publicly but
you know I think we might generously
describe it as situational flexibility
uh that in the current city
circumstances they see their best option
or their least worst option as a return
to Boris Johnson you know he really
might do this yeah but Alex when when
you speak to members of the public and
we've been speaking to lots of people
today in various constituencies
um and you look at the polling that that
would suggest that Rishi sunak is the
favorite at the moment for the public
rather than uh Boris Johnson to to to to
lead the country certainly if that if
there were an election tomorrow
it look it depends entirely on um who
you ask and I've seen plenty of Vox pops
on your channel but I must say
particularly more on others uh where
people have been more supportive of of
Boris Johnson in the end Vox pops ain't
gonna get it done and members of
parliament will think they've got a
sense from their constituents of where
sympathies lie of course it's the people
who self-identify as most interested who
Express themselves valuably who are
heard more than others and in the end
the only vote that really matters is
when you go to an election and there are
plenty in the Tory party this may be an
outdated view there are plenty of people
in the story party who think that Boris
is an election winner I'm staring down
the barrel of the current polling
numbers as they are they think why not
give it a try yeah let's have a look at
from the daily mail
um interesting front page Jessica from
the mail could borrow some wishing now
unite to save Tories this is it touching
on what you said earlier I mean there is
a Chasm between these two isn't there
um can you see a scenario where the two
of them could sit down together over the
next 48 hours and come up with sort of
some sort of plan and what would it be
what would it look like
bluntly I
threadably High ly hard to envisage any
scenario where this is possible I mean
the the two
um remember the the excuse and you know
this is probably rooted in some truth
that Richard Cena gave for um resigning
from the government was that him and uh
Johnson were supposed to give a joint
speech on the economy
um and they could not agree on their
economic plans they had just they just
had was so Divergent in their view of
what of what the economy needed that
sunak felt he had no choice but to
resign and obviously there were many
other things that that fueled that it
was his deep reservations about
Johnson's character both of those things
haven't gone away but the first one is
particularly important at this at this
time because you know if the two of them
couldn't even agree on her on an
economic approach in the summer and they
certainly when they're staring down the
barrel of this winter and the economic
turmoil that Liz trust's government has
caused you know it's it's it's you know
to me I'm completely implausible they
could try and find a a way now I would
think it very unlikely that sunlight
would be prepared to serve again under
Boris Johnson and you know should should
sunac offer offer Boris Johnson
Something Like Home Secretary I I don't
think that there's I I find it very I
would find it very uh difficult for him
to uh to to do that
um you know and and on what would be the
price it would you know strike me it's
very surprising if one were to drop out
of the contest for the other yeah can
you see any scenario Alex work where
that might work
why would either of them back down at
this point there's so much to gain and
so
um little to lose by trying and
contrero-wise so little to gain by doing
a deal now I just don't see it we do
respect people we've written the story
the future of the party Alex
yeah well but of course each of them
believes that they are the future of the
party just as we always say and point
out to people who have this corrosive
view about politics that um yeah they're
all in it for themselves and so forth
people go into public service to try to
make a difference and do good on both
sides of the house but also people don't
just pursue these things for personal
ambition although admittedly and
obviously it plays a part they also
pursue great offices of State because
they genuinely think they are the best
person for the job and the thing about
these people all of them now who are in
this field they genuinely think they're
the best people to lead the party it's
not just because you know they want to
preen and and say look at me it's
because they genuinely think and some
many viewers will think they're
profoundly wrong but they genuinely
think lead the country on our party yeah
um fascinating isn't it and we we will
talk plenty more about this uh between
now and midnight thank you both for the
moment coming up after the break calls
for Liz trust to turn down 115 000 pound
yearly allowance for former Prime
Ministers so
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we'll speak to our paper
reviews again in a moment but first of
all some breaking news we understand
that Boris Johnson former prime minister
is now on board a plane in the Dominican
Republic he's about to take that
overnight flight with British Airways
back to the UK you can see him there in
that uh snatched photograph looks like
he might be sitting next to Carrie his
wife about to leave the Dominican
Republic and head back to London uh amid
speculation that he is going to aim to
be the next leader of the conservative
party uh we'll bring you more details on
that as we get it but as you can see
Boris Johnson cutting short his holiday
in the Dominican Republic and heading
back on British Airways flight to London
Jessica and Alex are still with me uh
Jessica there we are Boris Johnson is on
his way back what do you make of that
I mean there is something quite funny
about this isn't there in a way that
um you know so many
um MPS talked about having doubts about
Boris Johnson's work ethic and you know
commitment to the job and having a sort
of fly by sea of his pants approach to
being prime minister and you know we've
got the Prime Minister flying back from
a Caribbean holiday in order to try and
you know be the next be prime minister
again
um even though all of last week you know
the house was sitting it wasn't a recess
there was plenty of votes in Parliament
that he could have been attending but he
was on holiday and you know whether that
might make some MPS remember what it was
like having Boris Johnson as prime
minister is you know Perhaps Perhaps it
will and we're hearing Alex um he's
getting support John whittingdale and
Marie trevelyn Alex Sharma Jacob Reese
morg
um he could do it we're told by his
supporters
I think he really could uh do it and I
have been interested in the number of
people who are cabinet and former
cabinet ministers who've declared for
Boris Johnson the guido Forks website
it's got the rolling spreadsheet must be
getting 10 times the traffic they
normally do with no offense to those
guys uh and um it's been very
interesting to see the names that have
come out also very interesting to see
that they've got individuals who've
personally affirmed to Guido that they
do support Boris but for one reason or
another cannot be named so they're a
whip or they're a vice chairman of the
party and so forth so they're not
allowed to publicly declare their
support but they have um they have a
firm that they're going to do that I
think it's quite difficult to see a
scenario now where Boris Johnson doesn't
get over 100 and isn't in the ballot but
it was very interesting before the break
we were discussing Jessica and I were
having a discussion about what would
happen in that round and what you would
need to do if you wanted to exclude uh
Boris Johnson Jessica's theory was well
you just all need to Pile in for sunac
and I as in that only one person that
gets over 100 and I think that that
theory is now not going to work I think
Boris is going to get over 100 if you
were of the stock Boris persuasion you
would need to pile your votes in to
Penny mordant so that there are two
people above Boris Johnson it seems to
me they just can't do that now they
can't rig it the people who are of the
stop Forest movement are not going to
succeed he's going to make it to the
final two and if he makes it to the
final two he'll win with the party and
Jessica we have uh just had it confirmed
by our correspondent uh on board that
plane uh Boris Johnson uh his wife and
children all flying back economy uh
clearly very aware of the cost of living
crisis
yes or I mean Boris Johnson you know
famously used to privately complain
about how little he was paid as prime
minister and you know and he hasn't had
very long
um to make those very lucrative speeches
we know that he made one that was around
paid around 300 000 pounds for um you
know in between uh leaving Downing
Street and now but he hasn't had a lot
of those
um uh to really bulk up and so if he
wants to go back
um to him his very nicely decorated flat
in in number 10 then um you know he's
he's gonna have to go back to to that uh
meager six figure salary that he was
earning as prime minister yeah I don't
think Liz trust had time to uh
redecorate and put up new wallpaper did
she uh thank you both for the moment so
that breaking news uh Boris Johnson is
returning to the UK from the Dominican
Republic as you can see he is on board
that aircraft flying back to London
overnight his supporters have been
urging him to mount a comeback just six
weeks after he left number 10 after
being forced to resign by cabinet
Rebellion over a series of scandals